Democrats and some Republicans in
Congress are blasting the White House
over the reported security breach major
Garrett is also at the White House with
that part of the story major good
morning good morning the optics of the
president's meeting with Russian
officials were always problematic the
Oval Office accessed the last US media
kept out Russian state media allowed in
and now this new report even in its most
benign interpretation raises new
questions about the president's agenda
with Russia there's nothing that the
president takes more seriously than the
security of the American people
HR McMasters comments did little to
satisfy Republicans or Democrats in
Congress both said questions lingers
Republican chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee bob corker
said the White House is in a downward
spiral House Minority Leader Nancy
Pelosi said such a disclosure could put
lives in danger it could undermine a an
operation that could be saving lives and
it undermines the trust that we would
have with our allies lawmakers were
careful to say they need more
information but concern was widespread
it's accurate to be troubling I have no
idea it's disturbing and let's find out
what the details are the suggestion that
he might have shared highly classified
information inappropriately with the
Russian Foreign Minister is deeply
troubling time that the we're having
discussions with the Russians and their
sensitive information involved yeah that
concerns me we can't have someone in the
Oval Office who doesn't understand the
meaning of the word confidential or
classified during the campaign candidate
Trump was critical of Hillary Clinton
who the FBI said mishandled classified
information on her private email server
she's guilty of the server she is guilty
of you look at confidential information
I mean all of the information that
probably has gotten out all over the
world the White House communications
team huddled for hours to deal with this
story and after McMasters denial it
announced to reporters it would answer
no more questions that's a luxury
charlie lawmakers are unlikely to
indulge thanks major